Speaker 1: Ladies and gentlemen, we are very
quickly approaching a full scale European war
between Russia and Ukraine in just a period of
a few hours, things went from U.S. intelligence
believes a large invasion is coming within the
next 48 hours and then just a few hours later,
bombings starting all over Ukraine by Russia.
Further, Russian troops entering Ukraine and we
are now in the middle of a full scale invasion
of Ukraine by Russian President Vladimir Putin.
There were still people, even up until
minutes before saying This is not likely
to happen. It's not likely. It just doesn't
seem like it's what Putin wants to do.
And yet it is what's happening, and we are doing
the best we can to keep up with all of the news,
which is changing very quickly. Let's just start
somewhere with the headline Russia invades Ukraine
in Europe's darkest hours since World War
Two. Reported by Reuters. Russian forces
invaded Ukraine Thursday and understand that
it was Wednesday night in the U.S., being seven
hours later in Ukraine. It was early Thursday
morning in a massed assault by land, sea and air.
The biggest attack by one state against another in
Europe since World War Two. Missiles rained down,
Ukraine reported columns of troops pouring across
its borders from Russia and Belarus and landing on
the coast from the Black and Azov Seas. Ukrainian
troops fought Russian forces along practically the
entire border. Explosions were heard before dawn
and throughout the morning in the capital Kiev.
Three million people in the city. Gunfire rattled,
sirens blared and the highway out of the city
choked with traffic as residents fled. Russia
attacks Ukraine, peace in Europe, shattered, as
reported by The Associated Press. Russia launched
a wide ranging attack on Ukraine Thursday, hitting
cities and bases with air strikes or shelling
civilians piled into trains and cars to flee.
Ukraine's government said Russian tanks and troops
rolled across the border in a full scale war.
Could rewrite the geopolitical order and whose
fallout already reverberated around the world
in unleashing Moscow's most aggressive action
since the Soviet invasion of Afghanistan in
1979. That's 43 years ago, Putin deflected global
condemnation and cascading new sanctions. This is
now starting to pull in other European countries
in the sense of triggering NATO's Article four.
Estonia, Latvia, Lithuania, Poland and
other allies are holding consultations
under NATO's Article four after Russia has
attacked Ukraine under Article four of the
Naito agreement, the allies can hold consultations
whenever they feel the territorial integrity,
political independence or security of an
ally is threatened. This is the next signal
of what could be next and what could be next would
be. And I mean, it's it's it would be something
approximating the scope of a World War, and I
I don't want to be hyperbolic, but when we are
talking about a full scale invasion by Russia, of
Ukraine and by Russia of Ukraine, and then we are
talking about the surrounding allies, including
Estonia and Latvia, Lithuania, et cetera,
getting involved. How can I not say we're talking
about something approximating a world war?
I was going to report to you today.
U.S. warns full scale invasion of
Ukraine could be imminent. This was again in the
afternoon. Yesterday, the story was, we believe
the intelligence points in this direction.
It could be coming. It could be 48 hours.
And then within hours, it happened, within
hours it happened. Biden warns Russia of further
consequences after Putin's declaration. It's going
to get very ugly politically and economically.
Biden issued a statement Wednesday night
condemning Russia's President Vladimir Putin's
announcement of a quote special military operation
in Ukraine. Moments before Ukrainian cities were
bombarded by Russian missile strikes. Consider
that there were people. There were people up.
And I mean, some this morning are still saying it.
But there were people up until last night saying
everything Putin is doing is justified because by
not ruling out that Ukraine will ever join Naito,
Putin is justified in everything. The
invasion, the bomb, everything. Got some real,
real problems out there. Putin sent in troops
disguised with white peace monitors, symbols and
Ukrainian officials, folks. It's a full invasion.
Troops entering the country from Belarus were
reportedly disguising themselves in Ukrainian
military and police uniforms. We have various
locations of where explosions were heard. We
have a map up on the screen and as you can see,
it's basically the entire country as of
this morning. The western piece of Ukraine,
which borders Romania, Hungary,
Slovakia has not yet seen explosions.
But you have locations where CNN heard explosions
and then locations were local residents reported
explosions. CNN reporting that the Ukrainian
Interior Ministry says they have experienced
hundreds of casualties from just the first missile
strikes. Hundreds already killed in Ukraine.
Speaker 2: The vibrations, obviously those
attacks, those missile strikes coming in much
closer is the sort of news that we've got from the
defense officials saying that this is now and this
is a quote I'm getting from the president's office
at the moment. A full blown nation wide attack
with military infrastructure that is being
attacked nationwide. So the emphasis being
on the military infrastructure that they say is
coming under attack. We've also spoken to again
our contact at the Interior Ministry, an Interior
Ministry official saying that across the country,
as a result of these attacks, there are
hundreds of casualties. Now, we don't know
how many of those people are dead, how many
are injured or whether that figure is accurate.
But we do know that the Interior Ministry of
Ukraine is putting the number of casualties so far
in this nationwide assault missile assault at
this stage, for the most part in the hundreds.
Speaker 1: And I apologize. I said hundreds
dead casualties does not necessarily mean
dead. It means injured or dead, and
we're still going to be standing by
to learn more about that. But it is. It is not
looking particularly good. The plan now is for
more sanctions. More sanctions world expresses
outrage plans, stronger Russia sanctions,
as reported by The Associated Press. World
leaders today reacted to the invasion with vows of
unprecedented sanctions, and we will we will focus
in more on the sanctions. And in another segment,
we have incredible video from Kiev's central
train station, just flooded with people trying
to get out of the city. Desperation rising. And
we're showing that video to our audience, just
people desperate to get out. There are reports
of troops coming into Ukraine, Russian troops
from all sides. CNN has video of troops crossing
the border of Belarus into Ukraine. That's one
direction from which they are entering.
There are reports of Russian military forces
entering Ukraine from Crimea, making that invasion
from eight years ago all the more relevant
today. This is going to be painful for Russia. I
mean, the Russian stock market down 40 percent.
It's it's, you know, if retaliation really gets
going. And Ukraine says there has been some. We
don't know the full scope of it yet. It is going
to be painful for Russia, but it's not clear Putin
cares. Ukraine's military says its air defense
did shoot down a Russian plane in eastern Ukraine.
Ukraine is saying anyone who's ready and able to
hold a weapon can join territorial defense forces
and understand that the Russians will want
to persuade Ukraine to surrender. And not
only are they launching a multi origin
multiplatform attack, they are also likely
to use disinformation, fake video and fake
photos to encourage that Ukrainian surrender
and the next several days could be some of
the most insane we have seen on this planet
geopolitically. I don't even I don't even
know since when in a very, very long time,
and the threats are now starting
to come to the United States